prêt alors que joe biden devient le 46e
président des états unis quel bilan
économique tirées des années trump élu
sur un programme populiste promettant de
ramener des emplois au pays donald trump
at il tenu ses promesses
le niveau de vie des américains s'est il
amélioré pendant ces quatre années et
plus généralement dans quel état les
ch'ti de la première économie mondiale à
son successeur
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques bonsoir c'est fanny
alors jacques ce bilan économique de
donald trump et du trump is me
globalement positif comme on l'a souvent
lu et entendu
alors oui il est clair que le bilan est
plutôt positif même si il faut dire que
cette année la dernière année du mandat
de trump a été quand même terriblement
perturbé par l'aco vide 19
alors oui effectivement c'est donc un
monde c'est donc si vous voulez des
résultats positifs sur la question de la
croissance sur la question du chômage
mais en même temps il faut souligner
qu'il y avait eu dans le mandat de trump
une réforme fiscale extrêmement
avantageuses pour wall street et donc on
peut se demander si donald trump n'a pas
finalement choisi wall street contre
mainstreet ou connaissait cette
expression américaine qui veut dire
choisir les milliardaires contre l'homme
de la rue alors jacques comment les
américains jeu style cézanne et trump
sur le plan justement de l'économie
c'est ça qui est extrêmement intéressant
c'est de voir que les jugements sur
l'économie et donc sur donald trump
dépens de tout à fait de l'appartenance
partisane des gens et on l'a vu avec les
sondages de sortie des urnes
après l'élection présidentielle si vous
voulez les gens qui considéraient que
l'économie américaine était florissante
et bien ils ont voté à 78 %
pour donald trump les gens qui
considéraient que l'économie était
plutôt en crise ils ont voté pour 80%
pour joe biden même chose si vous voulez
les gens qui considèrent
globalement que leur situation que que
l'économie va bien
et bien ce sont des gens qui ont plutôt
voté pour donald train et les gens qui
n'ont pas considérer que l'économie
était quelque chose d'important pour les
choix qu'ils avaient fait en termes de
président eh bien ils ont plutôt voté
pour joe biden donc en réalité cette
question de l'économie elle est aussi
une forme de division entre les
électeurs de train et les électeurs de
joe biden alors parce que c'est un
jugement un conforté par les crée oui
tout à fait alors si on regarde le taux
de croissance il est évident que au
moins dans les trois premières années de
son mandat
donald trump à assurer une croissance
plutôt supérieurs à ce qu'avait eu ses
prédécesseurs
alors si vous voulez il y avait eu les
deux mandats de barack obama le premier
mandat avait été quand même marqué par
la crise de 2008-2010
il y avait eu avant les deux mandats de
george w bush et le dernier mandat avait
aussi été affecté par la crise de 2010
mais si on prend par exemple le meilleur
mandats de george bush le meilleur
mandat de barack obama est bien on
obtient des taux de croissance qui sont
inférieurs aux taux de croissance qui
ont été obtenus dans les grosso modo
trois premières années du mandat de
donald trump donc oui effectivement sur
la croissance donald trump a comme on
dit fournit des résultats tout à fait
intéressant et comment cela s'est il
traduit concrètement pour les américains
alors pour les américains ça s'est
d'abord traduit par un niveau d'emploi
tout à fait important et ça c'est
quelque chose de très fondamentale si
vous voulez
les statistiques de l'emploi montrent
que le taux de chômage alors que ce soit
le taux de chômage officiel où que ce
soit le taux de chômage un petit peu
dérivé qui regardent plutôt l'emploi
précaire et l'emploi des des personnes
qui sont en dessous d'un mi-temps bons
que ceux sous quel que soit l'indicateur
que l'on utilise et bien là on voit que
très clairement le taux de chômage a
fortement baissé et que à la fin de 2019
au début de 2020 en réalité on était
arrivés sous donald trump à des taux
d'emploi qui était supérieur au taux
d'emploi qui avait pu être ce que ce
soit soudeur de bouche ou évidemment
sous barack obama et même sous clinton
donc il y a à l'évidence un succès la de
donald trump alors pourtant jacques il
ya eu des mesures qui ont davantage
avantages et les grandes fortunes comme
la réforme fiscale par exemple
oui c'est évident c'est évident et dès
donald trump a pris une réforme fiscale
qui a énormément avantager les plus
riches qui a comme on dit a avantagé au
wall stree contre mainstreet bon
maintenant il faut quand même un petit
peu modérer ce jugement en rappelant qu'
une grande partie de la classe moyenne à
travers les fonds de pension et bien
elle retrouve son intérêt dans la hausse
de wall street une hausse qui était
absolument un spectaculaire et là encore
si vous voulez un point est intéressant
parmi les électeurs des deux camps 48%
considérer que leur situation était
meilleure en 2020 en dépit de la crise
d'oka vide qu'elle n'était en 2016 alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que sur ses
48 % qui pensaient que leur situation
s'était améliorée
72 % avaient voté pour donald train et
26% pour joe biden alors jacques on a
aussi beaucoup parlé de cette action de
donald trump par rapport aux traités
multilatéraux quel bilan auquel bilan
avec le temps alors en tirer
effectivement c'était un point important
dans la politique de donald trump et là
il ya plusieurs choses à dire la
première c'est que effectivement donald
trump s'est retirée du traité
transatlantique à ce qu'on appelle le
taffetas il a provoqué une renégociation
de ce qu'on appelle le traité de libre
échange de l'amérique du nord l'alena ou
en américain le naphta et pointent
encore plus important et c'est peut-être
le point qui avait donné le plus
d'espoirs aux gens il avait introduit
une clause de salaire minimum de manière
à pouvoir justement contrer les
pratiques de dumping social donc de ce
point de vue là il a fait pour le coup
là des choses plutôt positive alors à
mais il n'est pas seul imagine jacques
wi fi gure il ya d'autres aspects qui
sont des aspects plus négatif alors le
premier aspect plus négative évidemment
c'est la politique des sanctions et la
politique très unilatérale menée par
donald trump en continuité là il faut
quand même le souligner avec la
politique avait mais qui avait été mené
1 par barack obama
et puis surtout il y a le conflit
commercial avec la chine
un conflit qui a été extrêmement
important on est arrivé entre les deux
pays à une forme de trêve ou de paix
armée avec l'accord qui a été signé à la
fin de 2019
bien sûr les états unis ont obtenu
quelques avantages mais c'était très
loin d'être tous qu'ils avaient voulu et
on comprend que sur ce point on restera
dans une situation extrêmement
conflictuel avec la chine
certainement dans le cadre du mandat de
drogba et d'un et des mandats successifs
alors joe biden va-t-il prendre le
contre-pied de tout ce qu'a fait donald
trump
ce actuellement s'il voulait sur toute
une série de points
il est très clair que thomas hayden
voudra marquer sa différence avec donald
trump d'où effectivement le décret sur
le retour dans l'accord de paris mais
sur le fond il faut bien comprendre que
ça va se jouer autour de deux choses qui
sont extrêmement importantes
le premier point c'est qu'elle relance
ou quel soutien apporté à l'économie
américaine qui est aujourd'hui
extrêmement affecté par la crise de
lakovic 19 et là on voit que les deux
présidents enfin donald trump et joe
biden était d'accord pour apporter un
soutien important
après ils différaient sur son ampleur
sur les méthodes on sait que donald
trump était partisan d'un chèque envoyé
à toutes les familles américaines à
chèque de 2000 $ les démocrates des jo
byden eux ont d'autres idées
ils veulent plutôt jouer une relance
structurelles bref né il ya à l'évidence
la 1.1 point important et puis l'autre
chose qui est importante c'est que joe
by dane a proposé de soutenir les
petites entre les petites et moyennes
entreprises americana c'est une très
bonne idée
il faut le dire tout de suite parce que
ce sont des entreprises qui ont besoin
surtout après tous les avantages qu'ils
ont été données aux grandes entreprises
d'avoir d'une certaine manière même
espèce de d'argent en 22 ballon
d'oxygène
aujourd'hui le point qui est gênant dans
la politique de joe biden c'est qu'il
voudrait justement favoriser plutôt les
petites et les moyennes entreprises qui
appartiennent à des minorités
alors il vise évidemment les petites et
moyennes entreprises de la minorité
hispanique de la minorité
afro-américaine et ça si vous voulez ça
risque de créer un problème politique
sur quelque chose qui devrait être en
réalité un très consensuel parce que je
ne vois pas d'américain s'opposer à
cette aide à des petites et des moyennes
entreprises et donc qu'il soit en créant
un problème politique là où il ne
devrait pas y en avoir
c'est dommage mais on peut penser que
joe biden un risque de compromettre
justement cette action de relance alors
à conclure comment jugez vous
ils ont économique de donald trump à 7
un bilan en demi teinte surtout par
ailleurs si on regarde les promesses qui
avaient été faites par donald trump lors
de la campagne de 2015 2016 si vous
voulez alors oui on ce qui concerne la
croissance et le chômage selon
l'expression américaine
il a fait le job il a trés trés de
manière très évidente fourni de bons
résultats si on commence à regarder la
question du commerce international et
des relations avec la chine
bon là on voit que le bilan est
peut-être plus en demi teinte
il n'est pas allé jusqu où il voulait
aller
il n'a pas été du tout capable
d'inverser le mouvement de déclin des
états unis qui sont aujourd'hui dépassés
par la chine comme première puissance
économique mondiale
et rappelons nous son slogan de
2015-2016 refaire des états unis
redonner leur grandeur aux états unis
vous savez great games à dallas de fait
il n'y est pas il n'y est pas parvenu
et effectivement peut-être le point le
plus délicat dans ce bilan c'est le
rapport qu'il entretient entre à la fois
les très grandes entreprises les gens
très riches et les gens qui sont
beaucoup moins riches et les légendes de
l'âme de la classe moyenne
et là on peut dire qu'il n'a pas eu une
politique cohérente avec son discours
qui était un discours de populisme
économique du moins en 2015 et en 2016
ce qui veut dire que la question du
populisme économique qu'ils soient mises
en oeuvre par un futur candidat
républicain où un candidat à la
candidature républicaine où qu'il soit
mis en oeuvre par des démocrates et bien
cette question reste toujours posée aux
états unis merci beaucoup je pensais
éclairage temps sur le 1000 ans sur les
haies fille
qui attendent joe madden merci à vous